le protocole de du collectif cédé par un
protocole de madame aux nerfs c'est un
protocole qui est fait par un collectif
auquel participent 300 médecins ce
protocole au moment nous parlons n'est
pas contestée sur le plan légal
il est inscrit sur un site et il était
promu en temps il ya dix mois m qui
rigole mais monsieur ahmed l'histoire et
doit moins rigoler parce que il fait la
promotion du vaccin alors que je peux
vous dire autre chose aujourd'hui on
peut parler maintenant que se bâtit du
danger de ce vaccin a été pendant l
danger alors cher monsieur vous pas
leurs noms mais juste tout égalise vous
parlez beaucoup j'ai ouï énorme
j'espère que je ne met jamais non mais
j'espère le monde et je vous le dis en
toute tranquillité j'espère que toulouse
est un l'un des meilleurs avocats qu'un
meilleur virologues épidémiologistes et
si je vous parle notamment des
traitements que vous proposez que
certains proposent lorsque je vous ai
dit on propose un traitement qui n'a pas
fait preuve de son efficacité s'appelle
du charlatanisme
lorsqu'on parle de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine par exemple lien annonceurs
à warlus sahara où il ya un médecin à
stanford qui a été soutenue justement
par le professeur raoul qui s'appelle le
docteur john le la disent oui qui vient
de dire et qui dans un article qui va
paraître dans nature demain ou dans
quelques jours je le connais très bien
que probablement nous avons tué cent
mille patients avec l'hydro xi
chloroquine voilà ce qu'il a dit dans un
enregistrement avec un article qui
apparaît comme ça ça veut dire malgré
tout qu'il ya une perte de chance
lorsqu'on propose des traitements qui
n'ont pas fait preuve de l'efficacité
alors je vous propose qu'une seule chose
c'est que vous avez un point commun avec
francis lalanne
non mais vous n'habitez de magma lorsque
vous êtes en état d'arrestation repose
une chose je vous prends moi j'étais
jeune il apprend que nous avons en
commun c'est que vous ne portez pas de
masse lorsque vous êtes à l'extérieur
moi je vous invite et à faire une chose
plutôt que de faire le beau là sur les
plateaux télé c'est devenir
m'accompagner sur le terrain ou
peut-être d'aller dans un service de
réanimation sans masque ou d'un service
d'une unité d'urgence ou là dans un
service comme guide et vous allez
apprendre deux choses la première c'est
l'humilité et la deuxième c'est qu'il
faut porter un masque pour être protégés
et un peu au-delà de ça vous verrez que
derrière tout ce que vous dites mais
finalement il n'y a pas grand chose et
aucun fondement scientifique et vous
fait énormément de mal dans l'esprit des
gens dans une période extrêmement
difficile et tendu non
un peu d'humilité peut-être que si vous
avez une passion pour la médecine je
vous invite à faire des études je dois
je dois vous répondra reste au lit je
dois vous répondre un an
il ya une décision du conseil d'état
italien qui a vu les corps at il ajouté
les abeilles jean littel paris avec une
cité oued ect nature moi je vous cite
décision du conseil d'état italien qui
considérait après avoir reçu tous les
rapports médicaux compétents en
processus de paix est parfaitement
miscibles en tant que poteau co2 soit
habitaient l'hydraulique l'origine avec
l'existant piscine est utilisé à
l'italie alors on est toujours dans une
série médicale
moi ça ne m'intéresse pas vous parlez du
masque les masques se souvenant d'avoir
des informations de les monter qui vient
de tous les enfants taux d'oxygénation
avant de commencer l'école je peux vous
on attend le niveau non mais on attend
du tout monsieur je me permets de vous
dire il ne feriez pas des ter gv moi qui
me parle je voulais jouer à la
physiopathologie on va jouer mais
assumez les moi je suis avocat je
traduis des choses peut-être un tour en
médecine j'ai vraiment ce salaire de
vous passionner l'air mais je vous
invite chers je me suis le parler du
taux d'oxygène à ses côtés moi je suis
pour le marcis absolument je suis un
baisser avant d'incarner bonheur
complotisme mal en point n'a aucune
envie de faire un tour d'un bouton vers
et faire un tour dans mon cabinet je
vote soit pendant qu'elle lui reste des
doigts de vos questions maintenant sur
le jeu sans vous dire madame bonnaire
aujourd'hui et s'est exprimé lors de
questions du gouvernement et la porte
est une question au ministre des dix ans
il y à des médicaments est ce que ces
médicaments sont plausibles
elle attendait une réponse hélas pas dit
que c'est absolument le protocole pour
soigner deuxièmement maintenant vos
nerfs n'a jamais exclu
et elle disait que des masques à
l'extérieur pourraient être évités et
l'a toujours dit que les masques à
l'intérieur était possible et ce qui est
dit est faux
maintenant vos nerfs est un député est
pas une scélérates et les paris sont
blotties serez mené sur des buts et du
mandat qui lui n'est plus de la
république un marche donc
automatiquement moi non plus